[Music]
ugh
[Music]
a horrible thing happened to you
i just want you to be able to move on
with your life
come here it's coming up on a year
i have something that's planned and i
need a partner in crime the b67 tv tower
i haven't climbed since becky if you
don't confront your fears you are always
going to be afraid
let's do it
let's climb your stupid tower
[Applause]
[Music]
i was really ripped you're awesome that
is the becky that we need for this trip
this is sick
damn it hunter what are you getting us
into
okay so just stay behind me one wrong at
a time
see
it's easy
you're doing great
becky you gotta come up here
[Music]
hey trust me
what was that
puncher how do we get down
i don't have a signal
the water is down there in that bag we
have 50 feet of rope
i think i can drop myself lower
okay i'm going to jump onto the fabric
every hour that passes the weaker we get
if anyone called 9-1-1 they'd be here by
now
what is it that dan used to say if
you're scared of dying don't be afraid
[Music]
you